our reporters are fanned out across the
country first owner Brian Ennis with me
here on pier 90 in New York City and
Brian good afternoon good afternoon bill
we are still awaiting for the first
patients to arrive on the USNS comfort
those patients are expected to be there
by the end of the day right now it's a
little bit of a slow roll but once the
process is set they're expecting up to
50 patients a day to be admitted on
board the Comfort this is non covet
patients only they are chosen by their
respected hospitals and then a group of
while state health officials and Navy
officials come together and they decide
whether or not they should be treated on
board the ship an ambulance will then
bring them to the Comfort after they are
checked to make sure that they do not
have kovat 19 by a tests at the hospital
and then screened once more this is a
very serious situation on board they are
treating everything as though everyone
on board has covered 19 the staff is
readied with really the best personal
protective equipment they do not want
this to spread at all the the patient's
do not have to worry about paying for
any of this the government is taking
care of this because this is a
humanitarian emergency they also will
not be accepting visitors on board
in the event of a COBIT case that does
make it on board bill they say that they
have isolation procedures ready to go
but bottom line is bill that we are
talking about some 1,000 hospital beds
but their greatest asset are the 1,200
medical personnel nurses surgeons
doctors from all up and down the East
Coast and when you talk to them they're
used to helping out other countries on
humanitarian trips the mercy and the
comfort but there is a special pride
that they are feeling that they are
docked here in New York Harbor to help
us really like to hear that two weeks
early - meanwhile across town center
parks are setting up tents they are
Samaritan's Purse that organization
alongside Mount Sinai Hospital has set
up a field hospital in Central Park a
remarkable sight they are expecting
patients there by end of day today we're
unsure we have not seen patients there
quite yet there are 68 hospital beds
including some 10 ICU units they will be
actually accepting COBIT 19 patients
which is different than what we've seen
at these other temporary hospitals at
the same time and announcement that a
new hospital has is opening up at the
Billie Jean Tennis Center in Queens a
temporary hospital with some 350
hospital beds this is where they play
the US Open Mayor Bill de Blasio's just
speaking there moments ago
not only help folks afflicted by a
corona virus help them to survive and
recover and go home it is specific the
only help patients who come through Alma
Hearst Hospital
there are 75,000 coronavirus cases in
New York Bilson 332 deaths in the last
24 hours
including the first death of a person
under the age of 18 but help is on the
way bill that just talked about a
thousand nurses coming some 250
ambulances from all over the country to
help me or Ken American right on that
we've known each other for several years
strangers live shots will
that's good thank you great to see
outside the company idea to see